so how do you celebrate Thanksgiving oh
well we usually have a big Thanksgiving
maybe for 40 people or so everybody
wants to come to my house because I
raise me I raise my own turkeys sure and
we have so we have heritage breeds you
know what here in his green shirt these
are no but I'm sure they taste great and
so I do three turkeys three different
ways and you do three different turkey
oh yeah three different different ways I
love that you said oh yeah like that's
not 30 people you need three true okay I
got you they're like 25 pounds each and
so we're doing a turkey and parchment
wrapped in parchment so you start off
baking it just at a low temperature and
then you raise the temperature when you
take the paper off it gets all nice and
glossy brown skin I bet you and we get
spatchcock spatchcock turkey ever do a
spatula what I'm just realizing that
there are three different ways of you
Turkey what did you say there are many
more than three we spatchcock you you
that's nothing dirty it's nothing dirty
it doesn't it means split the [ __ ] the
kohaku into a rooster
[Applause]
what it means is you take out the
backbone with a pair of scissors thread
it flat and it cooks in like a third of
the time that's so for those of you who
are oven
you know oven poor if you only have one
oven you have to bake the pies you have
to do all the sides you have to do the
turkey so you ever show it once you
whine enough already
oh me too I'm a lightweight I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this